from the air an assessment has made of
the damage caused by torrential rain
in new south wales capital sydney the
largest dam has overflowed flooding
neighborhoods in the city's western
suburbs
further north on what was meant to be
their wedding day a couple lost their
home as it floated down manning river
after bursting its banks
emergency services have responded to
thousands of calls from people who've
been left stranded
many more have been forced from their
homes
[Applause]
and there are warnings of more flash
floods in the coming days
with water levels not expected to
subside until
thursday our first and foremost priority
is to save lives save as many properties
as possible but also to give people
enough warning
of what's occurring and i appreciate in
parts of the mid and north coast regions
which
are experiencing the 1 in 100 year event
there's been sustained damage to
infrastructure there's been sustained
damage
to how people communicate and move
around and i just want to say to
everybody in new south wales who's
experiencing
that fear and that anxiety that our
thoughts are with you and we'll get
assistance to you as soon as we can
evacuation orders are now in place along
large stretches of australia's east
coast
and hundreds of people especially in
low-lying areas have been heading to
emergency evacuation centers
a severe warning is also in place just
west of canberra
just over a year ago these areas of
australia and many others were ablaze in
devastating bushfires
scientists say natural disasters are
becoming more frequent
and more severe due to climate change
and people are being urged not to drive
through flooded areas
because of strong currents
al jazeera